Speaker 1: Well, it's been a long, tough road
for the delusional, unhinged Trump fraud lawyer
Sidney Powell.
But it does seem as though her story has peaked.
And now we are.
We're really in the denouement.
As I like to say, this might be the last piece
of the story, as Sidney Powell has now reportedly
been banned from all of Donald Trump's properties.
Recall that she's been a beleaguered attorney
for a while now.
Early on in the 2020 voter fraud lies, she
was very involved.
She appeared at that mind-blowing press conference
where Rudy Giuliani's hair dye melted all
over his face.
And that's the one where she made the wild
claims about Hugo Chavez and Tifa Cuba, some
guy named Eric Coomer and many others.
At some point, Sidney Powell clearly was working
with Donald Trump.
But soon after that outrageous press conference,
the Trump campaign put out a statement saying
Sidney Powell is working on her own, trying
to create distance because what she did was
so humiliating.
But then she showed up at the Oval Office,
so it really wasn't clear what was taking
place.
Well, now she's been totally disgraced.
We've covered some of the really embarrassing
interviews that she gave in the last few months.
Her cohort, Rudy Giuliani, has been sanctioned
by various bar associations.
Trump has seemingly abandoned both Giuliani
and Sidney Powell.
But now, to add insult to injury, Powell is
reportedly on Trump's so-called no go list
at his properties.
The Daily Beast reports that quote Since he
left office in January, certain advisers and
longtime associates to Trump have kept an
informal short list of people who they should
look out for, including at Trump's private
clubs or offices in Florida, New Jersey and
New York.
The point of this roster is to intercept and
possibly rebuff attempted outreach visits
or phone calls from a handful of conservative
figures who could bring the ex-president more
undesired headaches.
This is expanded on further in a Daily Beast
article, which says, What does it say?
Sydney is very much on the no go list.
Her problems right now do not need to be the
former president's problems.
Powells legal exposure right now is, of course,
massive.
And ever since she tried to work with Trump
to orchestrate a coup last year against Joe
Biden, feelings of frustration and bitterness
have lingered between Trump and Powell.
What that means is, in the end, Trump will
turn on you in this case without you even
diminishing your support for him.
We know that if you go from 110 percent supportive
of Trump to 99 percent supportive, Trump often
turns on you anyway.
In this case, Sidney Powell seems to have
maintained her loyalty through and through.
She still is repeating all the same stuff.
But here it seems to be because she's so wacky
that Donald Trump is kind of backing off a
little bit.
I would imagine that Sidney Powell thought
she was going to get massive rewards and access
and fame and power for spreading the election
lies about Trump and doing the press conferences
and the like.
She did get fame, in a sense, for being completely
whacked out and disconnected from reality.
But we know what Trump does when people are
no longer useful to him, they might be no
longer useful to him because they've turned
on him.
People like Michael Cohen.
They might be no longer useful to him because
they don't have any more money and the election
is over like his supporters.
So he just tries to fleece them out of their
last pennies.
He doesn't care.
And they might not be useful to him because
like Sidney Powell, they've just been ridiculed
and made fools of so much in the media that
they can't do anything for him anymore anymore.
And think about Sidney Powell, who would hire
her now for actual legal work.
I wouldn't hire her for, you know, a real
estate closing, never mind something like
what she was trying to do for Donald Trump
or anything in between, quite frankly.
So not going well for Sidney Powell.
Banned from Trump properties.
Not going well for Rudy Giuliani.
And what?
There are lessons here.
And one of the big, big lessons seems to be.
Donald Trump will turn on you no matter how
close.
No matter how much he seems to like you, he
will turn on you.
And even now there are reports we don't we
don't know to what degree they're true.
There are reports that the relationship between
Trump and Ivanka, as well as Jared Kushner,
have started to deteriorate because Ivanka
seems to think some of the stuff Trump has
done over the last few months continuing to
push the voter fraud lies is just making him
look bad, which of course it is with much
of the world.
But his own supporters absolutely love him
for it.
So that's the latest.
Drew, if you invested in Rudy's stock, you
would be down right now.
If you invested in Sidney Powell stock, you
would be down even more.